they're gonna kill us all if we don't  fight we are in a valley surrounded by a  ridge to the north there's a river to  these there's a war you will not live to  see tomorrow no because of what you did  we need to move I want the demons to  leave and I will fight we are advancing  with speed after the enemy now we have  to get back until the people were at war  [Music]  so if I were to allow one more you're  going to get one more white man you  cannot face my lord on Judgment Day what  you worried about her you're not here in  the woods all alone no but you should be  you should have never come here  this is how in your home will birth  there's something in these woods  this is Mohawk LAN we're in their house  you